again
thank you everyone for joining i will
just in my part of the presentation go
over a little bit of
what you will learn in this particular
program introduction to dubai
informatics
discuss some of the technical steps that
you will be able to complete after you
learn about the different types of omix
data and show you a little bit of the
hands-on how you will use the learning
to actually start doing bioinformatics
as you prepare hopefully for more
in-depth learning that will be covered
in tomorrow's webinar on uh data science
and the webinar for orientation to the
transcriptomics program which will
happen on uh friday
let me go ahead and start sharing the
screen
so introduction to bioinformatics is
really a high level
program that is designed to introduce
you to the key elements of computational
or information technologies and biology
or the study of living organisms and one
of the
kind of interesting things i think about
bioinformatics is that it really
provides an intersection of informatics
and how to manage analyze process data
statistical analysis including finding
patterns in noisy data and then
biological interpretation and so all of
these elements are going to be linked
together in a series of these
asynchronous modules that you will be
able to complete over this semester
now the applications of bioinformatics
have really tremendously impacted
different aspects of research
biotechnology and translational
biomedical research and so what you will
learn in this program will provide you
with some insight into how that has been
changing over the past maybe decade or
two as the complexity of data has really
transformed the need for higher and
higher computational
complexity and analytical complexity to
extract meaningful patterns from big
data in a lot of cases this has led to
many approaches to different types of
treatments and diagnostic assays
as well as design strategies for
experimentation so what we will try to
do in this particular program is kind of
talk a little bit about how a biologist
or somebody with more of a life science
background can really start looking at
data and learn how to
process analyze and interpret some of
the patterns that are found in this kind
of data now what kind of data are we
going to be talking about
primarily
excuse me
primarily we're going to be talking
about next generation sequencing data
now next generation sequencing data
could be used to generate many different
types of omics data this can include
phenomics next generation sequencing is
typically associated with a phenotype
and that phenotype could be described by
how cells tissues and organisms function
or not function properly in the case of
disease it will also talk about some of
the elements like genomics epigenomics
transcriptomics and metagenomics and so
a lot of these are data sets that are
publicly available in various
repositories for example you can find
large quantities of research projects
high quality data available through the
national center of biotechnology or ncbi
including including repositories like
geo genuine expression omnibus
sra sequence read archive and others
where you will have an design of the
experiments or how the data was
collected
together with access to publicly
available data sets now there are over
80 000 publicly available data sets
just on geo which is process
transcriptomic data and so to prepare
the students and the faculty to make the
most out of these publicly available
resources and data sets this program
will provide you a good overview of the
different options that are out there
different data sets that you can get
access to and tools that you can use to
process and prepare this data for
analysis or use in your own independent
research project
so the introduction to bioinformatics
program will cover the following topics
we will talk a little bit about
bioinformatics in big data or how these
technologies have transformed the use of
data analysis to understand biological
phenomena we will talk about genomics or
the study of dna variation we will talk
about transcriptomics or how this next
generation sequencing technology could
be used to analyze mrna abundance and as
a proxy to protein that is being
translated from dna
we will also talk about some of the
statistical analysis and machine
learning so you will get a sense of how
the noise in the data the signal in the
data the large quantity and variability
of data are all leading the way into
more and more complex and sophisticated
analytical methods
now don't be intimidated by this this
will typically be reduced to you know
what anyone can try and use
without any in-depth understanding of a
lot of these methods just as a form of
introduction we will talk a little bit
about scripting so we want to provide
you with
some sense of what goes into a typical
bioinformatics project and that might
include
using user-friendly tools which i will
demonstrate today in just a few moments
it will also introduce you to some of
the commonly used packages so you
understand not just the black box of a
button that you press and get an output
but you really understand what goes on
behind the scenes and how this type of
uh kind of uh pro process
is conducted behind the scenes
and then finally you will be introduced
to some of the example projects and so
the example projects are going to
provide you with a variety of different
applications you do not have to complete
any one of those projects this is just
to provide you with a sense of what
kinds of projects could be done and how
do experts that publish using
bioinformatics utilize different
bioinformatics tools to extract
meaningful insights
so as already mentioned by lane uh you
will start this journey on this portal
learn
omixlogic.com
which seeks to connect all the different
elements of what i just described so it
will provide you with the coursework the
assignments the evaluations that we will
use in this program as well as access to
the different types of data sets and
practical tools that we will utilize
another simple way to find the right
resource on this page is to go and take
a look at some of the offered coursework
now anyone that registered for this
program has access to a variety of
different types of
resources that i want to show you
so this is where you probably registered
for the program and i just want to show
briefly that you can find on this page
everything that we are discussing today
in today's webinar so you will find here
the schedule that already was covered by
lane you will also see here the links to
registration if you are confused with
this ilab registration or you're not
from lsu or lbrn it's sufficient to just
register through this form and we will
actually reach out to you and confirm
what exactly you're interested in but
you will also find here some of the
modules that are included so what i want
to do is i want to just show you a
little bit how to find these modules
once you have created your account
so before i go on
maybe you could let me know in the chat
box if you have already completed your
registration on the learn portal so if
you have and i will just pause here for
just a couple of minutes if you already
have an account
please put number one
in the chat box so that i know that you
have completed your registration
excellent
now
if you have already completed your
registration you have an account
i will ask sonalika to now launch a poll
just so that we have a sense of who's in
this webinar today
and uh where you're coming from so
estonia could you please launch the poll
okay so it looks like the poll is not
available
uh let me actually change something real
quick
okay can you launch announcement later
you know i think you can go ahead i
consider the poll op option maybe i need
to relog in with the account and then
i'll just launch thank you
okay so um we'll continue and then
towards the end so if all of you
okay if all of you have already
registered
and you go to this courses area you will
find here several different things that
you can do so first of all
uh if you just register if you just
launched sorry if you just joined us i
see a question there in the chat you
just simply go
to this portal
and you register for free first of all
you create an account and once you have
an account we started going through some
of the specific courses that are
included in this introduction to
bioinformatics course and how to find
them
so you can find them in multiple
different places and we have heard a lot
of questions about where exactly to find
all of the curriculum what goes first
what goes next the first area that i
explained
just briefly is that you have the
central registration page
on this registration page it is
explained what the different options are
all of the different released
videos that you will be able to watch
asynchronously and then down at the
bottom you will see all the different
modules that are included including
here
you will see some of the people that
have completed some of these and what
they have gotten out of these modules
down at the bottom
now
you also have uh your page for the
program where you can find all of the
sessions that you can complete that will
be available to you only after you have
registered for the program
but as you complete these and maybe you
want to go deeper you will find here
different areas that you can search for
example if you're looking for more
in-depth view of let's say
transcriptomics you can find the course
right here if you're just getting
started and want to understand what is
going on in bioinformatics in general
maybe search for introduction to
bioinformatics
there are also
different collections of courses right
here so we are with the getting started
collection and under the getting started
collection you will get all of the
beginner level courses that include
introduction to bioinformatics a course
in python and r just to kind of get you
started with coding you will also see a
course called bytes and molecules where
you will see a lot of the information
that we will cover in this program
including the terminology about
different types of omics data and the
different types of biological
experiments that could be conducted and
data could be generated to study
different phenomena you will also have
some introductory courses specifically
to genomics transcriptomics and we're
adding
more and more resources into this course
to make sure that anyone who's getting
started has the terminology and kind of
a high level overview of what all of
these different elements are
what do they mean and how are they used
so you will also find
that under this
specific getting started link and i will
share the link right here too
there is a course called designing a
bioinformatics research project so lane
already mentioned this but you can
essentially learn about these data sets
and about the different use cases but we
hope that you take this further and
you're able to apply your own research
interest to the areas that are covered
by bioinformatics so you can identify a
project a data set in the research
question and essentially if you are
interested in that kind of a component
especially if you're a faculty or a
graduate student then we welcome you to
reach out to us additionally so that we
can explain how to best
leverage that in the context of this
introductory program
so now that all of you are registered i
see a lot of people have put number one
so i asked uh previously that if you are
registering foot number one in the chat
if you have completed your profile again
once you're there you can click right
here on your profile and like lane
already showed you will see your profile
with all of the information that you
need
about the different programs that you're
a part of etc
all right excellent so let's go to this
introduction to bioinformatics
program
um
okay let me just go to programs
and i want to show you where you can
have
access to our mentors
that will be available
throughout the program for any questions
that you have right so an important part
of this is that you're not on your own
you're not just doing this completely
asynchronously and have no one to talk
to
once you're a part of this program you
will be able to scroll down
and you will see that there is an option
to ask a question so to ask a question
you will be redirected to the slack
channel
and in the slack channel you can
communicate with other participants of
the program or with our team and so our
team is going to be monitoring this
we're not going to you know promise you
that we will answer all the questions
within
a certain time frame but we will be
monitoring this
introduction to
bioinformatics
program you can see that some of you
have already been added if you have not
been added to this program
please go ahead and click and click on
that link on that page
and and you can just say hello and that
way we can start getting connected and
kind of getting to know you uh through
slack now you also have
on this page if you have more in-depth
questions so especially if you're
confused maybe you feel frustrated with
something something's not working as
you're expected you also have here an
option to book a meeting and so if you
want to have
a meeting with someone from our team
you will see here a link to schedule a
meeting with sonalika who's also on this
call so that you can ask
you know specific questions uh maybe
technically you don't have access to
some part of your account
maybe you're stuck you don't know how to
move forward maybe something is not
working as expected right so first you
can talk to sonalika she will try to
help you as much as she can
if she can't she will also connect you
to one of us uh dr harpreet kaur who has
a phd in bioinformatics
if you are doing this online not from
lbrand or lsu if you are from ldrn or
lsu especially if you're a graduate
student or faculty we're also connected
with the faculty from lsu and from ldrn
and we would be able to connect you to
the right person to answer your question
this program is a part of a whole
network and so you will see that there
are a number of different resources as
already mentioned by lane
that you have access to including labs
support you know technical support and
advice from experts as well so please
make sure that you utilize these options
as well if you are joining this program
now another part that i wanted to share
today is that together with your account
you get an access to the t-value info
platform and so i want to spend the next
couple of minutes just briefly
explaining what this platform is and how
it's going to be utilized by those of
you that might not have any
bioinformatics background at all
once you have registered so again this
is something that might take a little
bit of time because maybe you've
registered on ilab maybe you directly
registered through the portal however
you register for this program this is
going to be a part of the subscription
so you will have some level of access to
this platform and what i will show you
today is just an example of a high level
overview of what is possible in this uh
specific program
so as i mentioned
there will be an overview of different
types of omics data including genomic
data transphomic data metagenomic data
so that you have a sense of what next
generation sequencing data looks like
and what to do with this kind of data
so first of all in this areas of
analysis section you can hover over each
different section
and learn about different types of
methods to produce this kind of data
as you go inside each section for
example we're going to be focused on
next generation sequencing data you will
see that right next to each section
there's also this i if you hover over it
will tell you a little bit more about
what this section does
now for those of you that are just
registering you have a demo account the
demo account is designed to show you
very quickly how the data was processed
and what is the typical output so to
explain i will show you a couple of
sections today so that you have a good
sense of what we're going to be doing
if you scroll
down to rna-seq chip and you open this
drop-down button
you will see that several exampler
projects are going to open up and the
first one is going to be this rna-seq
sale line project so we can go ahead and
click there
once you click here you will see an
interface that essentially represents
different types of methods with a visual
button
and the ones that you can press are
highlighted with this yellow uh
yellow line
so for example start is highlighted so
in the context of rna-seq essentially
these pop-ups will guide you to explain
what each button does and when you go
through those sessions that are linked
for example to transcriptomic data we
will go in depth into an overview of
what each one of these button does and
how to use them including how to build
different types of pipelines for
different objectives or different
research questions that you might have
in mind
here you will see the typical steps for
a
an rna-seq pipeline which includes
pre-processing mapping and
quantification and if you scroll down it
will also show you how to build such a
pipeline so let's go ahead and build it
once i click on ok you will see that
other buttons are now highlighted and i
can select from a number of different
paths to build my pipeline each path
will give me a different types of an
output for example
i can start by preprocessing the data
with trimomatic
pcr clean again once we get into this
module you will understand a lot more of
what each step does
and after that you can see that i can
click on bow type 2t
which is a method of mapping the
individual reads to the reference genome
and then i can quantify the level of
expression by using rsem or rna-seq
using expectation maximization
the objective of this step is to
quantify to give me a number for each
gene that i have in my table in the
annotation and each sample which is
where my data came from came from
biological samples
if i click on ok i will be able to click
on end
there's more information of course here
that you can learn about but in the
output files you will see a typical
output of this type of a pipeline so the
objective will be to really understand
how a pipeline or a combination of
multiple scripts and algorithms can take
raw data that we put in at the beginning
and produce some outputs that we can
explore right here
now after you've understood this basic
concept with something like rna-seq you
can now go back to areas of analysis and
see similar examples for other types of
data and so another type of data that i
want to briefly show you today is this
processing of metagenomic amplicon
sequencing
which
allows us to understand
diversity of
ecological microbiological samples
directly without culturing the specific
bacteria that we would like to study
so again you will have an introduction
to metagenomics in this introduction to
bioinformatics course you will see a
little bit about how this data is
prepared
you will also learn about specific
methods for example the data 2 pipeline
includes several different steps that
you will need to understand as you try
to analyze your data metagenomic
sequencing data and then how to
interpret this data as well so what is
the significance of different steps what
do these steps actually do
and how do you combine these steps into
a workflow to ultimately get a result
that you can critically evaluate to
understand
what it
means from a biological perspective now
sometimes you will have tables
sometimes you will have visual outputs
for example here we can download this
pdf file and see the output from this
pipeline provides us with a sense of
diversity
and
different types of
analyses that we can ultimately perform
to kind of understand the differences
between different types of samples that
were included in this particular project
so again each pipeline represents a
project a specific data set right so
each one of these demo pipelines
represents a different project example
and shows you how you can get from raw
data
to process
data that you can interpret or perform
downstream analysis
now as already mentioned
we will cover a little bit of everything
so if you go back to your program page
you will see here the schedule
will give you a sense of different
methods
different types of all mixed data
statistical analysis of omics data
including the introduction to biomedical
data science and so here with
introduction to biomedical data science
you will have access to this course
the course covers many different steps
for exploratory data analysis
statistical analysis of data including
machine learning that you will uh be
able to practice on the t by unfor
platform in the context of this
particular program
okay let me just stop sharing real quick
so that this loads
so in the context of this particular
program you will find this course
as a
user-friendly again series of pipelines
uh including some example data sets and
then if you're interested to learn more
we have two other programs that are
going to be introduced tomorrow for data
science which is going to be an in-depth
view of coding statistical methods
comparison and benchmarking of different
types of machine learning methods
including deep learning and the
application of these kinds of methods to
different types of large data sets
and on friday another orientation
session that will be dedicated to
in-depth transcriptomic data analysis
so briefly i want to show you those
forces as well
before i do are there any questions
about what we covered today
okay so if there are no questions
let me show you a little bit about these
upcoming courses the one that we will do
tomorrow which is called data science
for biomedical data again this is
sponsored by lbrn and biomed
you can see right here the orientation
session is tomorrow october 7th
and you will see a little bit more about
the different topics that will be
covered so we'll talk a lot more in
depth about the nature of these kinds of
data sets and what to do with them
starting from visualization to
exploratory analysis to statistical
analysis for hypothesis testing to
eventually machine learning and deep
learning as well
one of the differences between this
introductory program and the in-depth
programs is that the level of complexity
will increase
the number of hours that you're expected
to spend working on this
program the different assignments that
you will get will also increase and so
we have an equivalent to kind of the
academic standard the introduction to
bioinformatics is about one
credit course
training module
the data science is about a two credit
an equivalent of a two credit uh course
training module module and then the last
one which is going to be the
transcriptomics one is an equivalent of
a
three
credit course module so here you will
find also the link to the
transcriptomics module
and
i will just paste these links here as
well so this is going to be an
orientation session starting on friday
the previous course for data science is
going to be tomorrow so make sure that
you join if that is interesting to you
and uh all of these are asynchronous so
essentially you can start
learning already
after each session do not forget to
click on complete
uh the uh course so
here if we go back to our programs
uh you will find that under each session
you can complete that
session complete session and that number
one gives you points number two
ultimately after you complete all of
these sessions
if you scroll down you will see
that your name and the complete
certificate will be posted once you have
completed all of these sessions and
they're structured in such a way that
you should you should have plenty of
time to go through all of these
materials